women children and the elderly make up
the majority of the 11 million
ukrainians fleeing conflict according to
the united nations
they also filled the crematorius train
station in dinettes where a russian
missile struck on friday and i must say
in my 31 years as a humanitarian i've
rarely seen so much damage caused in so
little time the impact of the fighting
on the most vulnerable civilians was
presented to the united nations security
council on monday
in just six weeks nearly two nearly
two-thirds of all ukrainian children
have been displaced
they have been forced to leave behind
everything
their homes their school and often their
family members
families forced to split up to escape
the fighting are particularly vulnerable
to human trafficking and sexual abuse
according to u.n experts who said
accusations of sexual assault in areas
held by russian forces are on the rise
we know and see and we want you to hear
our voices that violence and rape is
used now as a weapon afar by russian
invaders in ukraine reports from kievska
herzonska and charningiskaubus
reported by the survivors themselves and
the by the witnesses
raped by a group of occupants multiple
times
with life threat to survivors their
children their family members
in front of the family members and other
people real cases real people real facts
russia's deputy ambassador denied the
accusations
no convincing evidence has been
presented for any of these crimes but
it's understandable that you have
trampled on the presumption of innocence
a long time ago but other council
members called for accountability
let me be very clear there must be no
impunity for crimes against children
in order to ensure accountability we
need to collect analyze and store
evidence on all crimes against children
more than 140 children have been killed
in ukraine with hundreds more wounded or
having lost a family member the united
nations says it can't confirm reports of
women being raped or of children being
sent to russia against their family's
wishes but it's calling for a full
investigation and respect for
international law
kristen salumi al jazeera the united
nations